the art of standing completely still and
then Wow in the crowd the Dutch city of
Arnhem is once again hosting the annual
world living statues festival this time
with entries from 24 Nations there are
three awards up for grabs decided by a
jury and the public Patrick van Horn is
in the professional class he makes
around 50 paid appearances a year and
already scooped the Belgian
championships back home last summer
this is his second attempt at the world
crown he kept the Mesa costumes I do
most of my costumes myself but I had
this one made because it was so
difficult
there are familiar old faces in the
changing area will you get a first
impression of the sheer variety of
costumes in competition one couple is
posing as figurines made from the
Netherlands famous blue-and-white
Delftware pottery the toughest part is
having a good idea a new idea for the
World Championships you have to be
original this participant from Britain
is going completely undercover people
walk past me they don't they don't see
me which is really nice so then when I
when I move I usually get a big surprise
time for van horn - likewise apply those
finishing touches in his case
camouflaged as a piece of wood here to
win I'm here to have a great day hair
lacquer helps to fix the makeup in place
before he dons his costume the foam that
makes up his coat is flexible enough but
when his performance starts the
transformation into hardwood sculpture
is complete once somebody throws a coin
into the bowl the action begins
it looks like he's made out of a block
of wood even his head is a mahogany like
shine looks great I have to laugh also
because of the play on wood you can see
it's made of wood part of being the
perfect living statue means finding the
right balance and that includes between
the still and moving parts of the
performance occasionally the public
manages to surprise the artist once
there was this old lady who was moved to
tears by my ass she even hugged me and
at the same event there was also a man
who took photo after photo of my
pedestal although I wasn't standing on I
was taking a break at the time the world
living statues festival is overseen by a
jury of three experts but the overall
vote is split 50-50 with the public's
opinion there are no set rules for
determining what exactly qualifies as a
living statue we look at the way their
days are designed the quality of their
the costumes and the makeup and we look
at the way of interaction gaming and
playing with the audience that's a very
important thing you can do much or you
can keep it subtle as a living statue I
do prefer interaction which is subtle
all contestants appear onstage once more
before the winners are announced and
then the wait is over Patrick run horn
finishes in second place he's beaten
only by a Dutch group called
philandering which means amazement
speaking of which I wasn't expecting it
a massive surprise a moving moment for
the Masters of immobility plus 1000
euros not a bad payoff for just standing
around